مختار زاده مواطن سويسري استثمر في سندات
بمصرف كريد سويس يشعر بالاحباط بعد ان
ابلغه موظف في البنك ان قيمه سنداته قد
انخفضت
ما حدث مؤسف للغايه مصرف
مقابل كسره خبز فقط الاملاك العقاريه
لكريدي سويس تفوق قيمه هذه المقايضه
الماليه وهذا خفض من قيمه اسهمنا انها
صفقه القرن ليوبيس لتفادي مثل هذه
الانتكاسات يحاول بنك يو بي اس الذي
استحوذ على مصرف كريدي سويس ترميم صوره
القطاع المصرفي السويسري معتمدا على اكثر
من تسعه مليارات يورو تعهدت الحكومه
السويسريه بتوفيرها لتحمل الخسائر
المحتمله جراء عمليه الاستحواذ تحرك اسهم
مؤقتا في تهدئه الاسواق لكنه لم يفلح في
الاجابه عن سيل الاسئله التي تواجه القطاع
المصرفي السويسري
سيتاثر الاقتصاد السويسري وسينخفض حجم
القطاع المصرفي ولن تعود معجزه المصارف
السويسريه الى ما كانت عليه من قبل مساهمه
البنوك السويسريه في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي ستنخفض
استشراف يضاف الى التوقعات القادمه التي
تلقي بظلالها على موظفي كريدي سويس فالملك
الجديد اخبرهم بانهم سيواجهون اياما
واسابيع عصيبه وهو ما اعتبرته النقابات
تمهيدا لحمله تسريح جماعي قد تطول وفق بعض
التوقعات اكثر من عشره الاف موظف سمعه
البنوك السويسريه على المحك تلك قراءه لا
تغيب عن تقييم مع ظم المحللين الاقتصاديين
الذين يستشرفون تراجع ثقه المستثمرين
بالقطاع المصرفي السويسري بعد ازمه كريدي
سويس ايمن زبير الجزيره جنيفر
[موسيقى]